a Republican congressional report says
the Obama administration deliberately
misled Congress and the public in its
efforts to funnel billions of dollars to
Iran as part of the nuclear deal
correspondent Rick Jetson has the
specifics tonight from the State
Department after signing the 2015
nuclear agreement Iran had a six billion
dollar problem the nuclear deal gave
Iran access to its international bank
accounts one account in Oman held about
six billion dollars in local currency to
use it the Iranians needed to convert
that money first to US dollars then to
euros and the Obama administration was
ready to help I think they did so
because they were desperate to get a
deal so on the one hand they were saying
that the Iranians were not going to get
access to the American financial system
on the other hand they actually granted
Iran a specific license to allow them to
take some of the funds that had been in
escrow a report from the Republican
majority of the Senate permanent
Subcommittee on investigations says the
Obama administration bypassed existing
sanctions and cleared the way for Iran
to use the US financial system even as
officials claimed that would never
happen the Senate report cites pledges
from then Treasury secretary Jack Lew
and other top administration officials
Iran will be denied access to the
world's most important market and unable
to deal in the world's most important
currency the report says that in January
2016
Iran complained about its nearly six
billion dollars stuck in an omen bank
one month later the Obama Treasury
Department issued a license allowing a
transaction the federal government would
otherwise prohibit officials then tried
to persuade two US banks to execute it
the report says quote both US banks
eventually declined primarily due to the
unwillingness to take on the legal and
compliance risk but also reputational
concerns in doing business with a
comprehensively sanctioned country like
Iran a former administration official
refused to go on record though tells Fox
News the license fulfilled US
commitments under the nuclear agreement
to quote give Iran access to pools of
its money held overseas the specific
license cannot be described as granting
access to the US financial system as for
what happened to that six billion
dollars in Oman the
report says Iran likely retrieved it
gradually using European banks Shannon
all right Richardson at the State
Department we'll have more on that
coming up thank you